[Musique]
salut ça va bah ouais ça va ça fait
longtemps le face caméra sur youtube
clotilde oui je sais pas à la dernière
fois que je suis en face caméra sur
youtube c'était il ya
[Musique]
moi je suis petit chez lui si je suis
créatrice de la chaîne passé sauvage
qui est une création de 2016 qui donc
vulgarise l'archéologie l'anthropologie
et ballet science du mano au sens large
mais moi ma formation c'est celle
d'archéologues
j'ai un master recherche en archéologie
qui agit sous marines notamment 2015
était annulée avait pas de travail en
archéologie ça a duré cinq ans la
génération youtube on a tous le même âge
et on a à peu près tous fait aussi ce
choix de lully risation grand public
notamment sur youtube
l'année où j'ai lancé ma chaîne
j'avais aucune idée quatre mois avant
que j'allais être sur youtube mais
j'avais fait le constat que je ne
pouvais pas faire une thèse à ce moment
là
je ne trouvais pas de mes cv ne vais pas
de réponse sur mais sur les candidatures
pour des fouilles
je m'étais inscrite à un concours pour
être institutrice et je détestais ça
c'est le jeu va j'arrêtais pas de voir
que c'était pas fait pour moi ce n'était
pas fait pour moi c'était pas le moment
et grâce à ma une soeur un peu plus
jeune que moi qu'elle ait 18 ans à
l'époque et qui du coup ben était
beaucoup plus en lien avec le web elle a
montré des vidéos de gens comme
ma nombril cyrus vance sylla buste
et du coup j'ai commencé à regarder j'ai
aimé ces vidéos j'ai été consommatrices
au départ nota bene aussi évidemment est
en fait à force d'être de consommer ces
vidéos pas j'ai fait ce constat il n'ya
pas de shenzhen archéologie
vidange et qu'ils aient été là mais elle
était pas forcément ce que moi je
voulais faire parce que c'était plus du
divertissement ça c'est un public plus
jeune et voilà j'ai fait constat que
baye avait déjà très peu de femmes et
pad archéologie anthropologie en 3 j
allais rien rien rien il ya toujours pas
à pas grand chose voilà donc la cd être
cédés moment une fois qu'on est diplômé
on a 25 ans 11 ibaf si je tente un truc
maintenant qu'est-ce que je vais faire
[Musique]
ça a été des montagnes russes tout ça a
été terrible mais parce que bon ça fait
partie de mon caractère c'est à dire oh
c'est super ça va puis là ça n'a pas du
tout donc oui moi aussi j'ai pleuré des
larmes de sang devant adobe premiere la
première fois j'ai l'air ce truc parce
que il s'était passé je crois qu'au
lycée ont monté sûr je crois que monter
sur première mais alors c'est en
2007 2008 et voilà et j'ai roulé un
premier temps 2016
c'était horrible mais c'était d'une
violence je ne comprenais rien enfin
c'était donc je donc si c'était que les
découragements dire je vais pas y
arriver c'est nul mais heureusement
j'étais entouré j'étais entouré de
notamment de mon compagnon qui est
l'auteur aujourd'hui des scripts de la
chaîne qui aussi archéologues donc passé
soit je sais c'est un binôme aussi c'est
moi qui représente la chaîne mais
l'écriture il se fait à quatre mains et
même un peu plus maintenant parce que
travaillant en équipe mais voilà donc
les sacs j'ai mis quatre mois à faire la
première vidéo non pas l'écriture
l'écriture est assez cette vitesse et je
pense qu'elle s'est faite en deux
semaines
mais le montage c'était super dur et
heureusement il y avait youtube en fait
c'est youtube qui a sauvé youtube parce
qu'il y avait des vidéos notamment
franchement faut faut rendre il faut
remercier les ados qui ce film est à
l'époque en faisant des tutos et même
encore aujourd'hui c'est les meilleurs
tuto
parce que il parle il parle vrai ils
sont ils sont dans la réalité ils sont
pas dans la théorie et ça c'était super
métaux coimbra je me sers de kikoo 69
qui m'a appris à des rochettes
alors on les choisit parce que ce soit
en fait ils sont ces sujets sont choisis
à travers des discussions donc c'est
vraiment
constants c'est une espèce de régularité
avec le pirate à corte qui écrit les
scripts
ben voilà on on vit ensemble on
travaille ensemble on a tous les deux
archéologues we only l'archéo on vit par
qui ou parce que moi le côté métier
passion c'est pas je suis pas d'accord
avec ça c'est quand même cédé juste un
métier mais donc c'est des discussions
c'est des réactions parfois ce qu'on
l'entend beaucoup et ça parfois les
sujets naissent de colère c'est à dire
de colère par rapport à ce montant des
médias traditionnels on peut pas cacher
le fait que youtube les sujets qu'on
propose sont parfois en une contestation
au discours qu'on entend à la télé
peut-être qu'on peut parler d'autre
chose que des rois on peut parler
d'autre chose que des pyramides de
l'egypte antique même des mayas ou alors
on peut en parler différemment c'est à
dire ne pas prendre que l'objet
magnifique riche la parade apparu comme
comme sujet premier mais peut-être qu'on
peut aller s'intéresser aux
populations c'est à dire les populations
rurales qui sont majoritaires donc toute
l'histoire de l'humanité sur tous les
continents
la démarche scientifique sur youtube
ouais elle est
difficile à tenir non pas comme on
pourrait le croire
[Musique]
par jeu c'est pas une attente du public
le public il faut lui faire confiance le
public qui n'a pas du tout besoin qu'on
nivelle par le bas les infos au
contraire moi j'ai un exemple très
récent sur ma chaîne où j'ai traité d'un
sujet hyper compliqué mais franchement
là je serais même pas capable de le vrai
expliqué c'est un site en septembre
historique dans le sud de la france et
qui montre qu'
il ya des dizaines de milliers d'années
d'année les populations se mixer les
unes d'entre elles et qu'on n'a pas une
race pure de d'homo sapiens mais qui a
déjà beaucoup beaucoup mélange bref
cette vidéo elle était hyper complexe
elle était un chercheur du cnrs qui
parle comme un chercheur du cnrs c'est
la vidéo qui a fait le plus de vues en
cinq ans sur ma chaîne
[Musique]